[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo nouvelle saison saison
un peu particulière forcément raison an
de l'élection présidentielle qui arrive
très vite mais le principe reste le même
deux journalistes bonjour brigitte
bonjour c'est un élu qu'on passe au
grill de nos questions beau joyel brawn
pie v merci d'avoir accepté de vous
prêter à l'exercice vous êtes député la
république en marche les yvelines et
c'est brigitte qui dresse votre portrait
bonjour yale brune peavey bonjour vous
êtes avocat de formation engagé dans le
monde associatif notamment au reste du
coeur vous adhérez à on marche en 2016
vous apprenez le métier à l'épreuve des
faits en assurant la présidence de la
difficile commission parlementaire
d'enquêté parlementaire sur l'affairé
benalla vous remettez un rapport
remarqué sur les prisons après avoir
visité des centres pénitentiaires aux
quatre coins de la france et puis
l'année dernière vous déposer une
proposition de loi visant à instaurer
des mesures de sûreté pour les
terroristes sortant de prison alors
l'année présidentielle est lancée on
pourrait dire yaël boon vivez votre
collègue député tiffany degois hésitent
à voter emmanuel macron en 2022 et vous
vous hésité quand je n'hésitais
absolument pas je suis je me suis engagé
en politique vous venez de le rappeler
derrière le président de la république
en 2016 mon engagement à ses côtés est
intacte une volonté farouche de
redresser le pays de là l'entraîné sur
une voie de progrès
alors tout a été bien fait on a fait de
notre mieux je crois que cela les
français peuvent le reconnaître et le
reconnaissent on a fait de notre mieux
dans des temps difficiles on a eu la
crise des gilet jaune on a on est encore
dans la crise qu vide mais en tout cas
nous sommes unis une majorité diverses
unis derrière le président de la
république pour continuer à réformer
parce que nous avons encore beaucoup de
travail au parlement nous allons en
parler aucun mea culpa donc mais mea
culpa sur quoi qu'est-ce que vous
attendriez deux mois la taxe carbone
peut être auriez pu réagir plus
rapidement la crise des gilet jaune non
mais encore une fois je vous dis je
pense qu'on a fait de notre mieux face à
des circonstances qui étaient parfois
très compliqué nous avions un programme
que nous avons souhaité mettre en oeuvre
nous n'avons pas réussi à tout mettre en
oeuvre je pense à la réforme des
institutions qui a échoué avec un
désaccord avec le sénat les deux
réformes des institutions puisque nous
souhaitions également inscrire la
protection de l'environnement dans la
constitution et récemment le sénat a
également refusé d'avancer avec nous sur
cette voie de transformation de nos
institutions nous avons effectivement
échoué sur la réforme des retraites
puisque le texte n'a pas abouti donc oui
nous n'avons pas réussi surtout les
circonstances parfois ne nous ont pas
aidés nous avons également de grandes
réussites de notre quinquennat mais vous
le savez des promesses réunion n'a été
réélu sous la vème république sans
cohabitation pourquoi ils manuel macron
ferait il exception à la règle parce que
emmanuel macron porte une vision
aujourd'hui de progrès que nous ne
retrouvons pas ailleurs parce que nous
sommes unis derrière lui dans notre
diversité on voit des élus qui ont
rejoint emmanuel macron et qui viennent
de tous les horizons et notre majorité
s'élargit encore aujourd'hui derrière le
président donc unités action volonté de
servir de servir miel pour le président
de la république est de servir bien
évidemment tout premier chef nos
concitoyens très rapidement et à lebron
pv eric zemmour est partout dans les
médias certains sondages le donnent même
à plus de 10% je posais une question un
peu cash est ce que ça vous fait flipper
écouter aujourd'hui on n'a pas encore le
paysage politique bien stabilisée on
voit qu'il ya beaucoup de candidats
partout chez les verts à gauche à
l'extrême droite à droite nous nous
sommes unis moi c'est ça qui m'importe
donc est-ce que ça me fait flipper
aujourd'hui non ce que je suis contente
de voir en revanche c'est qu'il rentre
dans le débat politique
la situation à son égard se clarifie moi
je n'aimais pas les gens vous savez qui
joue sur plusieurs tableaux en même
temps qui ménage un peu la chèvre et le
chou pas le regarde on est clair ça n'a
rien à voir là on est clair eric zemmour
a arrêté ses chroniques y rentrer dans
l'arène politique est donc maintenant
nous allons pouvoir débattre avec lui et
débattre de tous les positions en
ensembles sont mieux établies on va
passer au sommaire de cette émission
l'ondé de choc de la sphère dit des
sous-marins arrive au parlement une
commission denquête pourrait voir le
jour au sénat le bras de fer entre le
gouvernement et les sénateurs a
peut-être peut-être déjà débuté vous
verrez le projet de loi sur
l'irresponsabilité pénale voté en
première lecture à l'assemblée le texte
vise à répondre à l'émoi suscité par la
mort de sarah halimi cette sexagénaire
juive tué par un voisin consommateurs de
cannabis et pour terminer cette émission
parlera budget le projet de loi de
finances a été présenté en conseil des
ministres ce mercredi avec douze
milliards de dépenses supplémentaires à
la clé pour l'année prochaine
pour commencer la crise des sous-marins
laissera des traces entre la france et
les états unis avec de possibles
conséquences politiques en france le
sénat devrait lancer une commission
denquête dans les prochaines semaines en
fait le point avec samia de sheer la
france aurait-elle pu voir venir la
rupture du contrat de vente de 12 sous
marin à l'australie pour le savoir le
groupe socialiste au sénat demande la
création d'une commission d' enquête et
l'a fait savoir avec force mercredi lors
d'un échange musclé avec le gouvernement
on croit que vous devez la transparence
et la vérité aux français vous la devez
également à la représentation nationale
donc je pense qu'il est important de
répondre à des questions simples d'abord
comment comprendre que ni l'elysée ni
matignon ni le quai nos ambassades nos
services n'ont vu sur entendu ce qui se
tramait on ne peut pas réécrire
l'histoire a posteriori ou alors
évidemment on s'érige en juge ou en
procurèrent ce que non je comprends
d'ailleurs que c'est l'intention du
sénat et vous aurez
suivez les provocations dont pas une
utilité absolue pour éclairer le débat
réactions virulentes dans l'hémicycle
florence parly peine à poursuivre son
intervention ces propos ont choqué la
gauche comme la droite quand un ministre
ou une ministre perd ses nerfs perd son
calme c'est qu'il est malade s il faut
que le gouvernement des mails macron
supporte qu'il y ait un parlement le
rôle du parlement c'est pas seulement de
faire la loi le rôle du parlement c'est
aussi de contrôler l'action du
gouvernement la semaine nationale n'a
pas donné son accord pour composer une
commission d' enquête à la demande du
groupe heller c'est curieux quand on a
rien à se reprocher soyons transparents
le président du sénat gérard larcher
n'est pas défavorable à l'idée d'une
commission d' enquête sur cette affaire
de sous marins mais la commission des
affaires étrangères devra d'abord mené
plusieurs auditions avant de décider si
une enquête parlementaire est nécessaire
le ministre des affaires étrangères jean
yves le drian et le directeur général
des renseignements extérieurs devrait
être entendue rapidement
il ya eu le brin de muguet tout le monde
a été stupéfaite cette annulation par
l'australie de cette commande il y à
l'évidence des zones d'ombré dans cette
affaire pourquoi l'assemblée nationale
at elle refusé une commission d'enquêté
je vous pose d'autant plus la question
que vous avez travaillé sur la confiance
et la transparence un dans les vraies
politiques vous savez mais un des
interlocuteurs le rappelait le parlement
a la possibilité et c'est son devoir de
contrôler l'action du gouvernement c'est
l'article 24 de la constitution
ce pouvoir de contrôle c'est un pouvoir
qui s'exerce de façon continue nous
pouvons exercer lorsque nous sommes en
commission permanente et moi en tant que
présidente de la commission des lois par
exemple lorsqu il y a eu des
dysfonctionnements en matière de
distribution des plis électoraux j'ai
convoqué le ministre de l'intérieur j'ai
convoqué les présidents des entreprises
concernées et j'ai lancé une mission
d'information qui rendra ses conclusions
d'ici une quinzaine de jours cela ça se
fait sans nécessairement passer par la
case commission denquête le contrôle
vise une enquête c'est pas du moyen
c'est plus approfondie on peut être
responsable aussi alors là je dis non
les commissions permanentes ont des
moyens donc ce contrôle il va
s'effectuer on voit bien qu'au sénat il
va y avoir d'abord des auditions de la
commission permanente à l'assemblée
nationale aussi ma ma collègue françoise
dumas entame également un cycle
d'auditions au sein de la commission de
la défense et puis il ya aussi un organe
bicaméral qui s'appelle la dpr la
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement qui est chargée du
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement en
matière de rendez vous la criée seca
mission d'enquêté nantes et j'y
participe également non je ne crains pas
vous comprenez les mots de florence
parly quand elle accuse le sénat de
prendre des habits de procureurs ce que
ce que je ce que je vois c'est que il
est impératif dans une démocratie que
toutes nos installations fonctionne
pleinement et donc que le père de son
but de procurer le parlement n'est pas
dans un rôle de procureurs l'objectif
n'est pas de mener des dons
d'exercer le contrôle qui a encore une
fois une prérogative constitutionnelle
et moi ce que je dis c'est que
finalement peu importe qu'il s'exerce en
commission denquête en commission
permanente en délégation l'important
c'est qu'ils aient lieu et effectivement
les ministres sont responsables devant
nous donc ils doivent rendre des comptes
nous devons de rendre des comptes aux
français les ministres sont responsables
devant le parlement après proposé qu'un
échec gouvernement sur cette affaire des
sous marins mais il faudra l'eau il
faudra le voir nous on voit quand même
très effectivement et vous l'avez
rappelé madame boucher on a tous été
stupéfait c'était un contrat important
on voit maintenant que la diplomatie et
les relations politiques au plus haut
niveau ont repris la main juste en est
le président et mais elle est mal entre
voilà il y avait un communiqué mais très
diplomatique est ce qu'on peut en rester
là est-ce que ça y est la sphère est
derrière nous tout est terminé pardonner
non ça n'est pas derrière nous encore
une fois le parlement va mener un cycle
d'auditions que ce soit l'assemblée
nationale ou le sénat où la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement donc les
investigations vont pouvoir avoir lieu
et il faudra tirer les conséquences
évidemment de ce qui s'est passé et
conséquences en tirer les leçons pour
que justement de telles situations ne se
reproduisent pas on a besoin d'une
défense forte on a besoin d'eux défense
euros jugement rio tinto peut être les
leaders en la matière en europe compte
tenu de nos présences et ça c'est très
important sur toutes les mers du globe
comme il ya le fait que nous à l'otan un
siège permanent au conseil de sécurité
de l'onu donc nous avons un rôle majeur
à tenir il faudra tirer les leçons de ce
qui vient de se passer et ne pas désirer
sur défense européenne commune ça veut
dire que la france ne peut plus compter
sur les états unis pour sa protection
bien sûr que si ce n'est pas ce type
d'événement même si les graves qui nous
fait revenir sur notre stratégie
d'alliance avec la plus grande migration
de sortie de l'otan pour vous pour moi
non évidemment non il ya un référendum
qui aura lieu prochainement nouvelle
calédonie si l'indépendance l'emportent
est ce que la france perdra toute
influence justement dans cette région
indo pacifique alors déjà nous avons une
influence qui résultent effectivement de
nos territoires d'outre-mer qui sont
présents encore une fois sur toutes les
terres du globe on à la nouvelle
calédonie on a également dans le
pacifique la polynésie française
maintenant évidemment que à mon sens la
pole à notre présence en nouvelle
calédonie est importante dans cette
stratégie là maintenant le référendum
moi je ne ne souhaite évidemment pas
présager du résultat qui auquel il
donnera lieu et je ne peux pas
aujourd'hui présager non plus des
relations que nous entretiendrons avec
ce territoire si jamais ils
choisissaient la voie de l'indépendance
donc c'est beaucoup trop tôt pour
pouvoir tirer d'ores et déjà des
conclusions sur ce point là autre sujet
à l'ordre du jour au parlement les
suites de la sphère sarah halimi le
gouvernement souhaite combler un vide
juridique mais le texte adopté à
l'assemblée nationale suscite des
critiques à droite comme à gauche
regardez ce sujet les signes est elle un
monde un gamin c'est un projet de loi
censé répondre à l'émotion suscitée par
l'assassinât de sarah halimi et la
décision de déclarer son meurtrier
irresponsable pénalement on démocratie
on ne juge pas les fous
en revanche et c'est tout l'objet de nos
débats
il nous faut pouvoir faire la
distinction entre
celui qui atteint d'une pathologie
psychiatrique
commettre des faits répréhensibles et
celui qui doit sa folie à la
consommation volontaire de produits
psychotropes
le gouvernement crée une exception à
l'irresponsabilité pénale si l'abolition
du discernement résulte d'une
consommation volontaire de produits
toxiques dans le but de passer à l'acte
l'article 2 crée de nouvelles
infractions si une personne commet un
crime pour lequel elle est déclaré
irresponsable pénalement elle pourra
quand même être poursuivi si elle a
consommé volontairement des substances
psychoactives en ayant connaissance que
cette consommation pouvait la conduire à
commettre ce crime pour la droite les
cas de figure sont trop limitées nous ce
que se disent en est simple quelqu'un
qui se droguent de façon volontaire ne
peut pas voir sa responsabilité est
exonéré vous vous ajoutez un critère qui
est de dire il faut qu'ils se soient
drogués dans l'intention de commettre ce
crime
c'est totalement c'est totalement
inapplicable à gauche on craint d'ouvrir
une brèche dans le droit pénal en gros
on va dire le 121 s'applique il y as
abolition du discernement
responsabilités pénales mais on va quand
même regarder si avant celui qui a qui
est passée à l'acte ne l'aurait pas
quand même bien cherché en 2010 9 58
personnes ont été déclarées
irresponsables pénalement il ya lebron
peavey avez vous la certitude la
certitude qu'avec ce texte le meurtrier
de sara lee mais aurait été jugée pas
condamner jugé
pour être très honnête non pour être
très honnête non parce que vous savez
nous faisons le droit nous écrivons la
loi et les juges chargés de l'appliquer
et les juges dans une démocratie juge en
fonction d'une situation particulière
d'un dossier d' éléments du dossier et
donc il n'ya rien d'automatique
coup de l'émotion je vous indique que on
ne peut jamais en matière de justice
avoir une certitude sur l'issue d'un
procès pénal et c'est heureux parce que
on est sûr de la matière humaine qu'est
ce que vous répondez à ceux qui disent
que c'est finalement une loi sous le
coup de l'émotion une loi de
circonstance de s'avérer steve mais la
législation ce fait elle est ancrée dans
la réalité vous ne légiférer pas en
étant hors sol en étant sûr de la
théorie donc là nous avions une affaire
qui a été absolument abominable qui a
suscité dans le jugement a suscité une
émotion dans le pays
considérables et les magistrats de la
cour de cassation nous ont indiqué que
il avait été finalement un petit peu
contraints de juger de la sorte parce
que il y avait un trou dans la raquette
de notre législation c'est ce qu'ils ont
écrit le président de la république a
souhaité que nous avancions et que nous
rectifions ce trou dans la raquette de
la législation et nous avons pris le
temps de le faire moi président de
commission des lois à l'assemblée j'ai
lancé une mission que j'ai confiée à
deux vraiment des à-côtés d'opposition
et à manger et je ne crois pas que nous
répondons à côté nous avons débattu
assez longuement dans l'hémicycle et je
crois que les dispositions que nous
avons créés sont bonnes dans le sens où
nous créons une infraction autonome
quand la personne aura consommé en
connaissance de cause du bébé comment
vous feront l'intention précisément dans
la prise de psychotropes ses skis
ricciotti vos reproches alors eric
ciotti nous reproche cela je constate
quand même deux choses qui
m'apparaissent très importante c'est que
une d'une part le parlementaire
républicain qui a conduit la mission aux
côtés d'une parlementaire de la
république en marche était d'accord avec
les conclusions de cette mission qui ont
été reprises dans le texte de loi et
deuxièmement que les républicains hier à
l'assemblée nationale ont voté le texte
qu'ils ont voté en faveur du texte donc
moi je veux bien qu'on vienne nous
expliquer que les dispositions que l'on
souhaite adopter et que l'on a adopté en
première lecture ne répondent pas du
tout à la situation sont complètement à
côté de la plaque mais en même temps
vous ne pouvez pas dans ces cas-là voté
favorablement sur le tech alors vous
inscrire pour mort et il a dit on ne
juge pas les fous mais en créant
finalement une exception à cette
irresponsabilité pénale est ce que vous
ne risquez pas d'ébranler finalement
notre édifice pénales non encore une
fois nous avons conservé la structure de
notre droit pénal qui est
qu'effectivement on ne juge pas
quelqu'un qui est considéré par les
experts psychiatres comme état ayant un
discernement totalement abolie en
revanche nous créons ce qu'on appelle
une infraction autonome qui est de dire
si vous consommez des stupéfiants que
vous savez que cette consommation de
stupéfiants va altérer votre
discernement et que vous commettez une
infraction dans ces cas-là ça constitue
une infraction autonomie dans les faits
c'est assez et câbles çà çà çà va pas
mener à des débats 20 entre experts et
juristes l'ailé des balles sont jamais
vain madame boucher c'est toujours ses
cinq démocratie c'est de débattre entre
experts c'est de débattre entre juges
pourquoi on souhaite la collégialité que
ce soit pour des expertises que ce soit
pour des magistrats que ce soit au
parlement la démocratie c'est le débat
et le débat né à mes 20 jan rouven
vivait une question peut-être un peu
plus générale la sphère halimi s'est uni
monde à faire d'anti sémitisme vous avez
vous même été je crois victime
d'antisémitisme
quel bilan vous tirer du quinquennat
macron en matière de lutte contre le
racisme et l'antisémitisme
c'est un des fils rouges de notre de
notre quinquennat
parce que et là je crois qu'il y à une
concorde nationale sur ce point il est
absolument intolérable que des actes
antisémites racistes que des propos
puissent continuer à être proférées nous
avons adopté des dispositions très ferme
dans la loi pour les combattre notamment
pour essayer de s'attaquer aux réseaux
sociaux dont on voit qu'aujourd'hui ils
sont vraiment le terreau est le
réceptacle de ce type de délit
maintenant il faut aussi et c'est
important une action très déterminé de
la justice de la police des magistrats
et c'est vrai qu'on a encore beaucoup il
ya des relents inquiétant dans les
manifestations anti pas sanitaires on a
vu sa maison on les a vus on voit des
courriers moi j'ai vois que vous l'avez
rappelé été victime d' insulte par écrit
j'ai ma permanence qui a été taguée
voilà on a effectivement un espèce de
climat délétère et il faut lutter sans
relâche mais à chaque fois moi ce qui
m'a frappé et ce qui m'a rassuré c'est
qu'à chaque fois sur ces situations on
trouve de la concorde nationale et on
trouve aussi bien voilà je vais des
soutiens de toutes parts et je crois que
là la classe politique sonore à faire
front face à l'antisémitisme racial et
on passe au plus de la semaine on va
parler financer un pool tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le projet de loi de finances a été
adopté en conseil des ministres ce
mercredi bruno le maire l'a ensuite
présenté devant les députés en
commission il défend ecoutez-le la
sincérité de son budget le projet de loi
de finances que nous vous présentons
fait un choix clair qui est celui de la
relance et de l'investissement quelles
sont les lignes de force qui ont été
celles de cette majorité depuis le début
du quinquennat en matière de budget et
de finances publiques
la maîtrise des comptes publics
la baisse des impôts et la sincérité
sincérité c'est de dire effectivement
chaque euro dépensé doit être financée
et c'est de reconnaître que nous l'avons
fait avec olivier du soft qu' il y a
deux objets qui ne figurent pas dans le
plf qui vous est présentée
le premier c'est le plan
d'investissement tout simplement parce
que cela demande du temps de discussion
et de concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux les élus locaux les chercheurs
les scientifiques et en deuxième lieu
les mesures pour les jeunes pour une
raison qui est simple c'est que la
conjoncture économique a radicalement
différente aujourd'hui nous sommes
confrontés à une pénurie de main
d'oeuvre qui change la donne en matière
d'emploi déjà bruno le maire vient le
dire il ya une brune pivette dans ce
projet de loi de finances il n'y a pas
le plan d'investissement il n'y a pas
non plus leurs revenus d'engagement pour
les jeunes à l'arrivée ce ne sont donc
pas les mêmes prévisions les mêmes
chiffres de déficit et éventuellement de
dell comment peut-on dire que ce budget
est sincère justement en expliquant ce
qui figurait ce qui n'y figurent pas et
en expliquant pour quelles raisons cela
n'y figure pas et ces chiffres sont
qu'adulte le revenu
et les français que leur dire du tout
que le déficit sera telle valeur ou la
dette at-elle à tel montant alors qu'à
l'arrivée ce ne sera pas ça ce qui
serait trompé les français c'est de ne
pas tenir compte de ce que nous allons
faire pendant les semaines et les mois
qui viennent nous nous avons comme
principe que nous avons été élus pour
cinq ans et nous allons agir pendant
cinq ans le revenu d'engagement gènes
qui est quelque chose de majeur pour
toute notre jeunesse qui va lui
permettre qui va nous permettre de
l'accompagner vers la formation vers
l'insertion vers l'emploi tout en et en
lui permettant de vivre dignement
c'est un formidable projet de société
pour notre jeunesse qui attend sous vire
souffert pendant la crise il faudrait ne
pas le faire sous prétexte que nous
sommes en fin de quinquennat et que
maintenant nous devons adopter le budget
il faudrait tout arrêter moi je ne le
crois pas 6000 ol rhône est honnête avec
les français mais il faut continuer à
réformer là c'est parce que nous avons
été élus pour cela six milliards d'euros
d'aidés promises par emmanuel macron en
quinze jours il est déjà en campagne
dans ces aides étaient d'ores et déjà
annoncées elles figuraient les principes
directeurs de ce budget sont notamment
un axe fort vers le régalien et dans les
6 milliards dont vous parlez il y a
l'augmentation du budget du ministère de
l'intérieur suite aux annonces du
beauvau l'augmentation du budget de la
défense l'augmentation du budget de la
justice je croyais le bruit cervelle
monde le sait aujourd'hui dans le débat
public ce sont des secteurs régaliens
qu'il nous faut continuellement
renforcée nous devons poursuivre cet
effort et ses engagements du président
de la république montre que ces efforts
encore une fois seront poursuivis
jusqu'au bout et c'est le cas les
azzurri en septembre 2020 serre et 12
milliards de hausse supplémentaire sur
ce budget pour l'année son chéri tu
auras liste donc c'est utile aux
français parce que mais excusez moi
madame boucher quand vous renforcer les
moyens du ministère de l'intérieur pour
renforcer la sécurité des français ça
n'est pas électoraliste nous devons agir
dans un but d'intérêt général alors
qu'en france est immédiatement comment
vous financer tout ça y est les brawn
qui veut on parle on parle d'un retour
de la réforme des retraites qu'est ce
que vous en pensez ce que vous y êtes
favorable à moi j'ai toujours indiqué
que sur le fond la réforme des retraites
était une bonne réforme c'était une
réforme de justice sociale suppression
des régimes spéciaux réforme retraite
minimum et alignement des des droits qui
permettent de se dire que la même somme
cotisée entraînent les mêmes droits pour
nos concitoyens je crois que l'
architecture globale de la réforme que
vous souhaitez la faire bonne je
souhaite la faire la question c'est
quand est ce qu'on l'a fait le président
de la république et le premier ministre
sont indiqués la feuille de route il
faut que la crise soit derrière nous la
crise et pinot étaient des informations
et charles d'un passage par
l'intermédiaire du budget de la sécurité
sociale vous avez des incidents majeurs
d'actualité série tout est possible
encore une fois moi je n'ai pas
d'information particulière sur ce sujet
là aussi vous dis moi je crois que la
réforme des retraites et une bonne
réforme est une réforme juste il faut
que les conditions soient réunies
conditions sanitaires conditions
économiques partenariat avec nos
partenaires sociaux si ces conditions
sont réunies évidemment il faut y aller
et seul le président de la république et
le premier ministre sont juges du moment
et de la réunion de ces conditions
certainement pas yaël boon pivert
président de la commission des lois
est-ce que dire la vérité aux français
c'est aussi leur dire demain il y aura
inévitablement des hausses d'impôt pour
réduire ses déficits et ses dettes ma
dire la vérité aux français c'est leur
dire que demain il n'y aura pas de
hausse d'impôts c'est une un peu un
manque sous notre notre quinquennat
bruno le maire l'a rappelé en commission
des finances nous avons sur la durée de
la mandature 50 milliards de baisses
d'impôts également réparties entre les
particuliers et les enseignes risette en
2002 vous ne vous engagez par là dessus
at on pas augmenter la fiscalité c'est
un engagement très ferme il n'y aura pas
d'augmentation de la fiscalité et la
dette qu'ovide a été isolé et bruno le
maire a présenté un plan d'amortissement
de cette dette là pour justement qu'elle
ne pèse pas sur les générations futures
merci est loin de cliver merci six jours
d'un merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivis c'est la fin de cette émission ce
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de parlement hebdo
[Musique]